in one word just one word what is your
professional style open I'm here with
Matt Mullenweg who is the founder of
founder automatic or the founder of
WordPress how does that work okay an
automatic is sort of the parent company
of wordpress parent company of
wordpress.com Akismet fault press
jetpack okay and so for people who don't
know and are probably not that many of
them out there on the internet what
wordpress is explain it to me in like
two seconds
sure so WordPress is an easy way to
create a beautiful blog or website and
you started this when you were an
undergraduate at the University of
Houston that's correct and so you were
coding away in your dorm room I know I
had an apartment okay expensive but yeah
I was studying political science but
really most of my time was spent on
working online I loved making websites
loved working with musicians in town and
I ended up dropping out so like a lot of
other famous entrepreneurs Bill Gates or
in your in your in your good shape
and you you were programming it but it's
an open source project and you explain
that to people who might not understand
how open source works sure so WordPress
is kind of like the Wikipedia in that
it's a part of the reason it's fantastic
is it has hundreds of contributors from
all over the world the release that's
coming out the 3.5 release has over two
hundred and sixty individuals that
contributed to it so that sort of
leverage contribute you meet programs
yeah you're actually contributing code
right many more that contribute we have
over 20,000 plugins thousands of themes
so the ecosystem around WordPress gives
it a a lot of power and flexibility when
did you realize that this was more than
just like a project that you were doing
on the side and realized that this was
gonna be a company and potentially your
life's work hmmm it was very much yeah
because the growth was very slow in the
beginning I was really just making it
for myself okay
and the fact that other people used it
was kind of a happy coincidence the
first time it seemed bigger to me was
the first translation so a fellow in
Japan had opened every single file
hundreds of files and gone through tens
of thousands of lines of code and
translated every English string to
Japanese and
this must have taken him hundreds of
hours so it blew me away and then also
seeing the software that I had worked on
in this foreign language I blew my mind
it was it was beautiful
you know Japanese script is so beautiful
that's what I thought about it as
something that maybe just more than
software from my blog okay and that's
around the same time we adopted our
mission of democratizing publishing for
the world and you really have I mean it
give us some idea of the scale of
WordPress use right now
sure so WordPress is not used by about
17% of websites seventeen one seven one
seven including forbes.com correct lots
of major media all the way down to blogs
like mine I mean ma ITT and that's the
beauty of the software is it's it's easy
enough for anyone to use and you know
tens of thousands of people start using
it every day the powerful enough that it
can work for New York Times The Wall
Street Journal reports right did we do
use it here and it's it's remarkable how
easy it is from I remember way back in
the day when you were literally to
publish something online you had learn
HTML essentially and another that was so
hard but it certainly made it was a
barrier to entry yeah and that's the
thing we want to make it again
democratize publishing make it easy for
anyone to have and not just the website
a beautiful website we want you to look
good online we I think we do and thank
you for that and so give me an idea of
the scale of the the company now you
you're right now you're in San Francisco
now a based were sheriffs our
headquarters automatics headquarters in
San Francisco for about a hundred and
fifty people and the interesting thing
about it is we're totally distributed so
that's a cross I won't say about a
hundred and ten cities ok and everyone
works from home on their own schedules
kind of like an open source project
Thank You Allie and is that hard to
manage I mean what is your what is your
title there do you have Yahoo CEO well
he brought in right uh-huh
so Tony Schneider I'm actually joined
about seven years ago well so we've been
working together for a long time now I
run all the product stuff um so that's
sort of my passion I go to bed every
night and wake up every morning thinking
about WordPress organizationally I would
say it's actually probably easier than
if we had an office partly cuz I'm on
the road so much yeah but if we weren't
distributed I don't think I could do
what I do with the product we all
communicate is almost knowing though we
communicate using blogs using work
um and it's 24 hours a day so how do you
it's an open-source project how do you
make money cuz you give it away right
it's free so the software's free and you
can sign up to wordpress.com for free
but we have sort of power features so
for 99 bucks a year you can get a pro
bundle gets you a your own domain okay
so you can be like your name calm as in
close to your name that WordPress
network video functionality ability to
tweet the fonts in the design a bit so
those sorts of add-ons even though a
very small percentage of the total user
base uses them a number adds up well
small percentage of 70% of the web is a
big number I think we really have time
for one more question here so if you
were to give any advice to somebody
who's sitting in a dorm room right now
hacking away at some personal project a
passion project what would it be what
have you learned that you pass on to
that person hmm I would say the thing
that sort of enabled us to grow the most
and also enables our distributed model
to work is the people and so you know
hiring and finding the best people in
the world and then most importantly this
is the part that I screwed up for many
years is giving them the autonomy and
responsibility to actually execute if
you let people empower them to do it
they do tend to do it and I found no
connection between educational
background or experience or anything
people rise to the occasion but you have
to give them the ability to